regarding the theme of Consciousness
it's prudent to give an explication here
as often at least I found that Mysteries
arise because we're calling different
phenomenon by the same term and this
applies to Consciousness which doesn't
refer to just one aspect but rather
several that can be delineated to
further differentiate I spoke to
Professor Greg Henriques on this very
topic I'm attempting to delineate a few
Concepts that is adjectival
consciousness adverbial Consciousness
and phenomenal Consciousness which I
believe is the same as p-consciousness
but if that's not the same then that's
four different concepts so what are they
can you give the audience and myself an
explanation as to when are some
satisfied but not others so that we can
delineate totally yep yeah and and
actually adjectival adverbial are gonna
when we use Pete when John and I
certainly use P Consciousness
phenomenological Consciousness is
reflecting on adjectival adverbial
Consciousness and John refers to John
verviki John verakee yeah because we we
then did a whole series untangling the
world not to make sure that our systems
were in line both in terms of our
definitional systems and our causal
explanatory framework so we did a
10-part series on just the two of us on
untangling the world not of
Consciousness uh and then we did one on
the self uh then we did one on
well-being and we also did one on
development and transformation with
zackstein
um so all of we our systems I think are
now completely synced up at least in
relation to the language structures uh
that we have and and so I can tell you
what we would mean by adjectival
adverbial Consciousness uh which then
sort of is what most people mean by
phenomenological consciousness okay so
if I understand correctly one has to do
with degrees and then another has to do
with the hereness and a nouness yeah
exactly so actually there's I like to so
I would encourage us to say that let's
define conscious there are three
different kinds of definitions of
Consciousness okay that I think the
first definition of Consciousness is
functional awareness and responsivity
okay this is something that shows
awareness and can respond with control
and at the broadest definition then even
things like bacteria can show a kind of
functional awareness and responsivity
okay that's the behavioral
responsiveness and when you say hey is
that guy conscious what you mean is he's
not responding at all okay he's not
showing any functional awareness and
responsibility he's either knocked out
or blacked out or asleep okay so when
you say Consciousness in that way that's
functional awareness and responsivity
which you can see from the outside and
you see in the way in which the agents
operating on the arena because they're
showing functional awareness and
responsibility okay
the second meaning of Consciousness is
subjective conscious experience of being
in the world the first person experience
a being and this is where the hard
problem of Consciousness comes online
and that's what most people mean by
p-consciousness or phenomenological
Consciousness it's a subjective
experience of being which is only
available from the inside out
okay uh so that's and then the final one
is a self-conscious access okay so that
now I can be know that I have had an
experience retrieve it and then in its
highest form report on it so
self-consciousness then it's the
capacity to recursively access one's
phenomenological thing and an explicit
self-consciousness which is what humans
have and other animals generally don't
is this capacity to say Kurt I am
thinking about your question I'm
experiencing your face and this is my
narrative in relation so that's explicit
self-conscious awareness uh-huh just a
moment you said access is that the same
as access Consciousness or is that's
different no that's net blocks access
Consciousness which basically there's
the do you have the experience and then
is there a memory access Loop that
stores it and then can use it so so if I
can gain access to it
um that's a sort of access Consciousness
is relates to that I want to make sure
that I understand this there's a door
behind me if I go and I access is what
I'm accessing qualia and is it the
action of accessing that's called access
Consciousness like the manipulation of
data or is right it's it's the well it's
basically so you have awareness and then
you have memory of the awareness that
you know that that some aspects of it
knows that you were aware
so it's like so you can imagine
awareness without really like one way of
differentiating it would be sort of we
have what a sensory perceptual awareness
that lasts say three tenths of a second
to three seconds it's like a flash okay
then you have working memory which
extends it across time and puts it on a
loop that Loop is what allows you to
then gain access to it and manipulate it
so working memory is a can be thought of
then as a part as a as the um uh the
white board that allows continuous
access to the flash so there's a Flash
and then there's the extension and
manipulation of The Flash which you then
need access to okay
uh the basic layers of this what John
and I argue is that out of the body
comes what we call valence qualia
valence qualia basically orients and
gives value to and can be thought of as
in like Pleasure and Pain in the body
okay and it yolks a sensory state with
an affective State and points you in a
direction a yoke means tie together like
to yolk stuff together so this is the
sort of the earliest form of
Consciousness is probably of kind of
valence Consciousness okay that
basically pulls you you know oh this
feels good feels bad kind of deal gets
me active gets me passive but it's this
sort of like hmm this kind of felt sense
of the body
okay that's the argument from John and
I's position is that that probably is
the base of your subjective conscious
experience or the base of your
phenomenological experience
okay
then what happens and that would be
maybe present in you know in say
reptiles fish maybe down into insects at
some level okay uh then the argument
will be in birds and mammals and maybe
lower we don't really know but there's
good reason to believe in birds and
mammals you get a global workspace
the global workspace is when it extends
from these sensory flashes into a
workspace where you have access and
recursive looping on it and and it's the
framing of that is is the
um adverbial Consciousness is the
framing and extension of that the
hereness nowness and togetherness that
indexes the thing pulls it together
that's what John calls adverbial
Consciousness okay okay
and then it's what's on the screen of
that adverbial conscious this is what
John calls adjectival Consciousness so
it's like it's the screen of attention
that orients and indexes that's
adverbial
okay and then what is actually the
properties that you experience that's
adjectival
first I came in with three questions and
I have so much so many more okay this
valence is it purely pain and pleasure
or is there something else are the third
fourth elements
um there's certainly pleasure pain
active passive to orient and like and
want basically so but but that gets you
know so but basically you have What's
called the circumplex model of affect
which basically is the core energizing
structure of your motivational emotional
in its broadest frame is two poles one
is active passive okay it's like sort of
spend energy or conserve energy and the
other pleasure that is either something
that you want or something you like or
pain that's something that you don't
want or don't like at its basic so
that's the so the valence is what we
sort of focused on in relationship to
just the ground of it but there are
definitely at least these two poles of
active passive and pleasure pain at a
minimum
can you make an analogy with this
computer screen right now so the
computer screen is somehow the workspace
and then the pixels and the fact that
they're bound together is adjectival or
the the intensity is adverbial or the
other way right like can you just spell
out absolutely right so the screening
the framing of the screen which brenn
basically says okay this is the frame
and the relevance and the hereness
noweness of what is going to be brought
that is adverbial that's what John
called adverbial Consciousness and he
has a whole argument as to why
especially through What's called the
pure Consciousness event that's achieved
in meditation and several other things
there's a differentiation between what
he calls the indexing function of
consciousness
which basically is the framing you bring
you index you say that thing without
specifying what the thing is okay it's
the that thing that brings it and then
you then discriminate on the properties
that's the diff that's the different
pixel shapes that give rise to a form
that give rise to it experience quality
and that's the uh adjectival quality so
and and these are both of these are
John's terms but I've Incorporated them
in my work and I use them okay another
analogy now to abandon the screen it'd
be like if looking is one aspect and
then what you're looking at is another
what you're looking at is akin to the
qualia in a pure Consciousness event the
at may not be there but you're looking
exactly it's the framing exactly index
framing that's why John Wayne takes off
his glasses okay the glasses are much
more like the adverbial framing they
pull and organize okay and it's a
looking okay the pointing the indexing
in fact he actually he uses work in
cognitive science okay where you can
track like if I give you like four
different things to track on a screen
okay and they're changing colors and
changing shapes four different things
you can track five six seven you stop
losing ability to track however what you
what you lose first is the ability to
track the specifics you can tell where
something is but you can't tell what it
is actually so in other words it's sort
of like you're trying to track
everything but it changes like from red
to blue to green you're much better like
I think it's over there
it indexes but I can't tell you whether
it's an a a b a red or a green I can't
tell you the specificity so in other
words I'm tracking The Entity okay
that's the index and that's different
than the specifying the nature of the
form and indeed we have lots of
different systems that track the like
what what is the Thing versus how is it
moving the how is it moving it's more of
an index structure but if we think of
this kind of bomian wholeness
we could say that the meta crisis is a
function of
missing bohmian wholeness and doing
optimization on parts
and so I can optimize self at the
expense of other but of course that then
leads to
others figuring out how to do that and
needing to for protection and now arms
races of everybody doing that and the
whole externality said I can opt to
myself at expensive other I can optimize
in-group at the expensive out group
I can optimize one metric at the expense
of other metrics I can optimize one
species at the expense of other species
I can optimize my current at the expense
of our future
all the way down to one part of self
relative to the other parts of self
so the wholeness of all the parts of
self
in Synergy and all of the people species
Etc and how to consider the whole how to
consider the effects on the whole
Maybe that was something that other
animals did not have to do maybe it was
something that even earlier humans
didn't have to do because they couldn't
affect the whole all that much when we
have the ability to affect the whole
this much this quickly
because of tech right because and
particularly because of exponentially
powerful Tech
whatever ways we are either consciously
saying this is a part of the whole I
don't care about or I'm happy to destroy
conflict theory or this is a part of the
whole I'm just not even factoring maybe
I don't even know the factor that's in
the unknown unknown set but I'm still
going to affect it by the thing I do
so
what is outside of my care or my
consideration right conflict theory and
mistake Theory
with exponential Tech gets harmed
produces its own counter responses and
Cascade effects the net effect of that
is
termination with this much power what
does it take to Steward the power
adequately is to think about the total
cascading effects of the choices
and all agents doing that and say how do
we coordinate all agents doing that in a
way that has the Integrity of the whole
upregulated rather than down regulated
and so I would say bomian
wholeness is a good framework for
alignment not alignment of an AI with
human intents
but uh but aligned with the
interconnected complexity of reality
may I inquire how did you attain such a
vast array of knowledge what's your
educational background what does your
routine look like for studying is it a
daily one where you read a certain type
of book and you vary the field week by
week what is the regimen how did you get
the way that you are
think my
learning process probably in some ways
similar to yours you said just very
fascinated and curious and
I mean you did it
you did something
better than I did which is you pick the
topics you're most interested and found
the top experts in the world that got
them to basically tutor you for free in
terms of like in aristocratic tutoring
system you did a pretty awesome thing
there
um
uh there were a few cases where I was
fortunate enough to be able to do that
other times I just had to work with the
output of their work but um I think for
me it was a combo of just innate
curiosity independent of any used
application and just
ha
I think it's natural when you love
something to want to understand it more
and so for me the impulse to understand
the world is kind of a sacred impulse
um but then also the desire to serve the
world requires understanding it well
enough to know how the to maybe do
that so there is both a very practical
and very non-practical
impulse on learning that happened to
fortunately converge and how is it that
you're able to articulate the views that
you have how do you develop them do you
start writing do you do it in
conversation with people do you say some
sentiment you realize you know what that
was actually pretty great I didn't even
realize I thought that until I had said
it now let me write it down so I can
remember it
you know I have hypotheses about how
people develop the ability to
communicate well but my hypotheses about
that in my own process are probably
different
um I think my own process is I was
homeschooled
and that was homeschooled in a way
that's maybe a little bit like what
people call unschooling now but my I had
no curriculum at all
but my parents just
had the kind of they they had never
studied Educational Theory they hadn't
studied constructivism and thought that
Montessori and Dewey's thoughts on
constructivism or right they just kind
of had a
sense that
if kids innate interest is facilitated
uh there there's a kind of inborn
Interest function that will guide them
to be who they are supposed to be
um so there were some downsides to that
which is
because I had no curriculum I didn't
have like
writing a letter a bunch of times to get
fine motor skills down so I have
illegible handwriting I know what the
shapes look like with my abilities
behind writing
I was spelled phonetically until I
became an adult and spell checker taught
me how to spell interesting um and so
like I missed some significant things
um but I also got a lot earlier deeper
exposure to the things I was really
interested in which were philosophies
spiritual
studies across lots of areas activism
across all the areas and Sciences
uh and poetry but uh
my
education was largely talking with my
parents and some of their friends and it
was largely talking
right I actually didn't it wasn't until
later that I did a lot of reading and
writing so I think it just was very
conversational it was very native more
than in a lot of people's developmental
environment I think that's the answer
for me I could say that for other people
I have seen when they start writing
and trying to say what is the most
concise and precise way of writing this
um that really helps also when they
start communicating with people and
getting feedback on their verbal
communication when they watch others
communicators that they really inspired
by and watch the patterns but I think it
was just that was pretty native for me
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy